comment malaise elle me dit ralenti je
suis pas bob marley il faut le faire
enfin son territoire
on a condamné chanel a fait toujours
rage de dents
voilà je vous dis benhaim elle a perdu
20 ans ont deux jours ouais ah mais
j'oubliais s'est terminée là benhaim
elle a une dent est là dedans en fait
médaille mal à une dent pour le steak et
une dent pour le fromage et le dessert à
tous les steaks qu'elles ne mangent là
tout ce qui est trois matches des décès
à qui alain calmât abbas peut ouvrir là
quand on va reprendre touche pas à mon
poste on bientôt tu vas voir qu'ils la
belle et elles vont se passer les
dompter un bibi mais ça va se passer
walla walla mais qu'elle soit mais
ça oui c'est mr fighters
alors ça je peux tenir tu arrives tu
mets deux autres dans et du ton sac soir
une pizza binebine terminé il fait tout
tout seul de gata justel vignonet de ces
moines osso buco tu mets un truc là bim
ils sauront ce book i want you were here
for him
regardez comment savoir la crème
regarder et là une crème
c'est une crème qui frêche c'est frêche
en toutes circonstances elle se réveille
elle est fraîche elle s'endort à et
fraîche et belle elle est bien dans sa
tête elle va bien avec le champignon des
oies ils sont cool tu vois pas les
prêches choix est très belle et très
frais choix tout le contraire de moi je
suis un jura si je sens de michelle sam
brûlé au bo d'élan
en de pierre un peu autour de la charte
est pour ça qu elle cherche encore dû
tomber qui venaient me parler en france
tellement des belges ou s'il vous reste
qu'avec moi j'ai loupé mon challenge et
la pizza trop brûlé
car j'allais oublier
tous deux travaillent on va la manger
tout à l'heure à tout de suite avec
jimmy mois mais le docteur thierry j'ai
fait une boutade en un instant va
continuer bien sûr le shebab accusés
mais là je veux montrer une files
d'attentes de fou s'est passé ce matin à
marseille
mais pour le moment la pizza est là faut
juste que je joue ce ce four
voilà alors là dix mois ouvrir un fort
c'est pire coin un coffre fort avoir l
appui là c'est pas plus je suis pas plus
cons que j'en ai les ébats et ben ali b
la pizza la pizza l'habitat je te veux
tu à quelles fins
à quel médecin
la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la ça rappelle la
coupe du roi 98 ça y est je vois plein
et merde
merci mais ça dans le micro